one thing we learned tonight even an
icon like Jennifer Aniston gets nervous
luckily her friends were close by it's
like having your family stand right
behind you because these things are a
little nerve-wracking
do you get nervous oh god I forgot my
beta blocker at home and literally just
went through you have no idea many
levels of panic Jen was honored at the
SAG after foundation patron of the
artists awards and only ET had the
exclusive backstage she inspires me
every day she's just so happy to be here
to support her earlier in the day
Courtney reunited with another friend /
husband Matthew Perry she posted this
shot with a very Chandler caption quote
could I be any happier Matthew and
Courtney got lunch together today we
don't get invited to that I cannot
believe those two last time I saw you at
the Variety event you said look you guys
have just done the friends lunch you got
to find the right project if it's not a
friends reboot what do you guys want to
do together
oh god that's there's there's a lot of
different ideas but who knows other
honorees last night included director
Ava Duvernay
and Mark Ruffalo who is co-star crashing
all night long you and Jennifer Aniston
starred together 15 years ago this year
was rumor has it a good appear here
tonight oh it's great to see him I love
her and we had a great time
then backstage mark posed with his
shutter island' co-star Leonardo
DiCaprio Leo presented mark with an
inspiration award for his environmental
work dare I say it he even went green as
The Incredible Hulk
[Music]